we just got Andrew Tate's actual revert
story from himself Insha'Allah let's
take a look at it Oscar now because this
is the Hot Topic especially in the
Muslim Community about your conversion
yeah so tell us the story like what
happened exactly well I think a lot of
people have been following me for a
while understand that I've been very
respectful of Islam for a long time I
was born in a Christian country I was
raised as a Christian and I've always
been very respectful of Islam and it's
become more and more obvious to me and
and more and more pertinent that Islam
is the last religion on the planet when
I talk about Islam because I'm new to it
yeah I I'm a little bit careful right
because I'm new to it I'm certainly not
a scholar there's so much I need to
learn I know I'm on a Learning Journey
I'm not here to sit here and talk
scripture I don't know those things yet
I'm here to learn but we're here at your
assistance thank you brother thank you
thank you but um it's just for me it
feels like the last religion on Earth I
feel like there's no other religion
people say to me why did you convert I
said I don't really feel it as a
conversion I it's almost like I knew Gog
was real and now I've become religious
and they say well you were religious
before I was like religious before how
Christian what does Christian mean like
who's not a Christian you go to
Christian nations and everyone says
they're a Christian look how they live
their lives go into the average church
is anyone actually fearful of God
anybody no the girls are out on Saturday
night drinking and they turn up to
church because their parents made them
but there's there's no substance to the
religion and also
Islam very closely reflects my personal
beliefs I through my personal life I've
learned that if you don't have standards
and you're not a strong person who's
prepared to defend his ideas you'll be
crushed yes and we look at most
religions in the world today which are
not prepared to defend their ideas
what's happened to them they're just
getting crushed and now we have
Christianity as an idea which is
basically said well we can't set any
firm rules because everyone will just
quit so instead let's make it so easy to
be a Christian that nobody has to put
any effort in and then accept everybody
no matter what and hopefully we can keep
the church's doors open that's not
that's not God to me you know God to me
is is strong God to me is something to
be feared God to me something someone
that people are afraid to mock yeah God
to me is someone that you have to go out
of your way to prove something to God to
me has red lines like God to me
represents the Islamic faith the
Christian God to me I don't see God I
can't explain I don't see anything there
so to me it was it was the only logical
choice in the end I mean many as you're
saying this I'm sure many people are
like ecstatic and extremely happy it's
great it's a great thing for everyone
honestly because you know just anyone
coming into Islam is you know the
prophet Muhammad is better than the
world and everything in it
but imagine now somebody of major
influence I mean you're the most Googled
person on the planet I'm not sure if you
still yeah I think Putin might have beat
me as of last week but I think it's
between me and Putin at the moment but I
don't want to lose Putin's the Big G I
don't want more enemies like it's fine
Vladimir you can have it I never thought
I'd hear you saying that statement yeah
put wouldn't beat me last year right
yeah I think we're just something to
most Google but no no it's definitely
something beautiful and a lot of people
have you know you'll be surprised at how
many women as well like because
obviously the the accusations of
misogynist you know but but a lot of
women handling especially in the Muslim
World they absolutely happy in fact let
me tell you a story just before I came
here today one um one particular woman I
can't remember her identity but she's
working as a school teacher yep in
London and um actually my friend told me
that she was kicked out of school yeah
because they had this campaign against
you in the schools I'm not sure if
you're aware of it yeah this was part of
the cancellation I didn't know about
this yeah yeah so in British schools
they said you know if you say anything
good about if you if you say anything
good about this person or you have to be
reported or what and if you say anything
you know you have to kind of combat
extremism or whatever it may be right so
she because when you became Muslim she
abstained from doing that she said I
can't really do that because you know
Islamic laws and it's it's backbiting
and he's got honor and Islam and so on
and unfortunately they fired her from
that from the position wow so you can
see that this is the level of
encroachment we're talking about here so
and this shows you that the level of
fraternity that exists and not only the
fact that you know when you're looking
at Old Twitter whatever Twitter or
whatever social media it's not a
representation of what's really
happening of course of course they fired
her bro
male love bless you and reward her and
give her that which is better Allah
she's not working at that school board
for that school that's going to make her
diminish her religion
I mean I mean uh he says something very
interesting in the beginning and I just
want to point out
to Christians this is exactly what Paul
did for the Romans where he mentioned
let's just make it so easy to practice
that everybody can be a Christian and
not have a problem because nothing
changes in their life except they say
this and they believe that I pretend to
believe that whatever it is that's
exactly what Paul did for the Romans he
went he said don't basically don't worry
you don't have to you know circumcise
your children you don't have to
obey any of The Commandments you don't
have to fast you don't have to like none
of this stuff don't worry about it keep
doing what you're doing
just believe just say I believe Jesus
died for my sins
and James contends with him
in the Bible it's actually recorded if
it is authentic whatever Bible we have
now James who is the brother of Jesus
and eventually be basically becomes the
head of like the the religious house at
the time contends with them and then
Paul writes basically like why are you
gonna be mad at me if my lie brings
people to believe in Jesus that's
exactly what he says so we're just
living Paulie in Christianity uh you
know on steroids nowadays that's that's
all we're living in
versions
the the Christian girls who uh they
basically
went on the the carousel they've been on
it for too long and then they they come
off and they're like I'm a reborn virgin
Born Again born again virgin a
born-again version
see the thing with Christianity bro
today it's boiled down to no
accountability
just desires whims and desires just
believe and you'll be saved that's nice
bro I'd love for something to be like
that bro but I can't ever accept
something like that because I know
there's no accountability I don't I
can't just do whatever I want to do
people be saved you know there was an
interview with uh with someone with a
woman bro they literally interviewed a
woman on the street asking
if some man commits XYZ to a woman
horrible things horrible things no
consent but he believes in Jesus is he
going to go to heaven and she's like of
course
and then they're like oh but if one
other man does like the most amazing
things never does anything against
someone's will really top G man energy
you know but he doesn't believe in Jesus
what's going to happen she's like well
you find out like how do you believe
that bro it's not logical it's emotional
but they're emotionally wrapped around
this you know you know speaking about
logic and emotion I just want to kind of
throw something that I've seen on here
and and let me just start this out by
saying Allah Knows Best
right Allah knows best and let me start
off by saying that I love this brother
Andrew for the sake of Allah I love
living before he became Muslim for the
sake of Allah then he was a very genuine
and I already knew that he was playing a
character his entire time to uh get the
business popping and all that stuff I
get it you kind of love a non-muslim for
the sake of Allah
yeah but look
energy is coming from a very logical
place and he has a very logical
understanding of Islam right now which
is beautiful you know I'm not going to
take anything away from that
the thing that I'm seeing though is that
and I might be wrong bro Alana's best
maybe I am wrong but from what I'm
seeing is that uh
Islam hasn't entered his heart fully yet
you know like once it enters the heart
like it's a different it's different
than the logical you know because like
one can have the logical but not have
like it in their heart and it's a
completely different way that they're
going to speak about Islam that they're
gonna practice this land that they're
gonna think of it and they're gonna just
feel about Islam so it's like I may be
wrong and I hope I hope I am wrong I
hope I am wrong but it's just an
observation I made and um if if it is
true
you know that Islam enters his heart
like as quickly as possible because it's
a it's a different feeling man it's a
different feeling so so real quick
before we wrap up this video what advice
would you two have
um to like quickly sum it up advice to
have Islam enter your heart because a
lot of people might be listening to this
video they're like oh you know what okay
cool but I'm also on the same boat
Romy do you have something to say first
I do but I I don't know if I should say
it publicly I was actually going to give
it to a friend of his to pass it on
because I don't want it to be like
coming from me I want it to be advice
coming from the Fred
don't no this is not this is not the
Andrew this is just anyone in general
bro this is if someone asked for anyone
watching that's like I'm logically like
cerebrally a Muslim but I don't feel it
I see you listen you want to feel
something you want to feel something man
listen to different recitations of the
Quran because maybe you'll find a
recitation in an Asura that really
impacts you and also
listen or read the Sarah of the Prophet
peace be upon him when I first started
practicing Islam that was what did it
for me that was the thing like I kid you
not I there was a playlist I don't know
if it's a lot back at the time you know
a few years ago I was sitting in my
mom's bed and I'm just going through
every single video
how the process synonym was born when he
was a child when he grew up other people
how would they love them before
prophethood when he became Prophet
everything till the death of process
center by the time I got to the death of
the Prophet Allah I was sitting on my
mom's bed bawling my eyes out crying
what about you bro
I agree 100 man
it's I was just going to say the
recitations bro but you were all right
man the theater like the life of the
Prophet Muhammad
like I was thinking about that the other
day and um
yeah like that that had mean tears bro
because it's like
there was the prophet Muhammad was
promised Jannah
like he was guaranteed Jannah
and he would always be seeing a stock
for a lot of stuff for like Allah
forgive us forgive us forgive us
and then there were times where he'd be
crying and he was asked like Yara soon
like why are you crying you know like
you you're guaranteed Jannah like you
were the prophet of Allah like why are
you crying and he's like I'm crying and
correct me for more I might be saying
this one here but he's I'm crying
because of uh
like the the people in in the future the
ummah in the future or the people who
are not going to be accepted into into
Jannah into the heaven into the garden
and it's like bro like just think about
this man's crying for people
who are going to be in the Hellfire who
are not going to be in paradise and it's
like
if someone's truly crying about that
like
that's that's unconditional love and
like usually the only real unconditional
love that we can see in this world is
from our own mothers like a mother's
love I'm sure I'm yeah even them bro
like but for the most part like a
mother's love is like one of the hardest
things to rival in this world
for a mother's love for her child now
you have this man who's literally has a
love that's stronger than that and for
people that he he doesn't even know he
hasn't even met yet
and like to me bro like that that made
me start breaking down the tears just
like thinking like damn like this person
loves me more than like my own mother
loves me and I never even met him bro
that's that that's a professional song
for you bro but sum it up real quick
guys for anyone that missed those two or
their minds were wandering number one
Quran recitations number two
um learning about the Sita the prophet
saws
I want to talk about the Quran
recitation thing too because two years
ago I came draw me with the same
question I was like bro I logically
fully like believe in Islam I have yakim
you know but how do I feel it and he's
like he didn't even say anything he just
sent me a video and it was like a Quran
recitation of samsura and then I
listened to it and I had translations
too he was like read the translations
while you listen to it and I did another
one and did another one it hits
differently hits differently bro so to
anyone that hasn't done that Insha'Allah
we recommend that check that out
um but with that being said
actually I want to caught one how do you
the process center in relation to what
angel said the processarily and I'm very
curious to see what Andrew Tate's gonna
you know how he's gonna react to the
theater of the process that I'm you know
with him being uh for a lot of guys like
a role model and an icon nowadays
I'm really curious to see what he's
going to say about the process what he's
gonna feel
and you know publicly
how he's going to how he's going to
interact with the people after hitting
this little process up because for me it
changes Allah changed everything for me
I will interact with people but there's
a Hadith
this is again in relation to what you
said on him where he's he was with his
companions
and he said I miss my brothers
I miss my brothers or something
something along those lines something to
that extent and the companions were like
we're right here where are your brothers
we're right here he's like no you're my
companions
my brothers are those who will come and
they will believe in me after never even
meeting me subhanallah
that's how he describes People Like Us
who believe the process I said I'm and
never met him a day in our lives
no no